ça oui
salut ça va ouais je suis désolé du
retard comme tanguay s'est pas de
provoquer ta commande et je vais
commencer par temps sec 6 ferme aussi
laissé dam des fans et oui je vais droit
de le série du jeune abbé s'il vous
plaît le plus dans son cas ça la cuisson
pour les anecdotes saignante
je comprends pas avoir déjà quand on est
un entretien droit je ne peux
m'expliquer ce que je fais là un coude
bien tom ou 25 ans né à paris tout ça
tout ça
parcours amoureux à premier bisou 12 ans
dépucelage 15
félicitations merci du côté des
dernières relations ave
sonia deux mois marie trois semaines et
l'isard mois et demi audrey de minutes
beaucoup de relations courtes vous êtes
un candidat un peu instable disons que
j'ai un petit peu de mal à garder un
emploi
c'est brett type de rupture en fidélité
ah ben non alors puisqu'on ne s'emballe
vide mais c'est vrai que j'aime ça a pu
arriver que je sois débauché à quelques
reprises où je vois quand même pas mal
de cdd vous avez peur du langage ah non
du tout moi alors moi le cdi c'est quand
vous voulez mais c'est vrai qu'il perd
17 passe pas toujours bien le quoi et
belles conditions d'entretien beaucoup
trop élevé c'est à dire tu vas tu votre
principal défaut je dirais
perfectionniste menteur annonce ici
c'est marc keller moteur principal
défaut vous avez des patients
oui à part branlée sur youporn je lis
des livres et bien je vous remercie
d'avoir des rapporté vous le poste
proposé malheureusement après un examen
très attentif de de votre dossier eh
bien j'ai le regret de vous annoncer que
votre candidature n'a pas été retenue je
me vois dans l'obligation de casse toi
suivant
je vous relate à tous les fonds bois
s'il vous plaît pas je les prie mes
rendez vous ça se passe jamais comme
prévu c'est fou allez c'est pas grave un
petit pot de glace on clique sur ce
petit macaron ayant sa bonne ouais bah
moi s'il ya bien un truc auquel je suis
abonné c'est les histoires qui se
passent mal donc si tu veux en voir une
autre avec vincent tyrrell eléonore cost
et battu cliquer sur le cv celle ci
allait aux cookies
sinon si tu veux voir d'autres vidéos
golden moustache cliquer ici